one that you
[Music]
nothing good is born from life and
greatness is not what you think
[Music]
there was no hope for this world it's
time for me to die these things we have
to accept no matter how much it hurts I
wish I was hopeful like you my mistakes
outweigh all the good I've ever done
find your mother tell how much I love
her
[Music]
so God and we're next
every second mother earth dies
this string is the annihilation of
[Music]
that'll not with monsters lest you
become a monster even in the darkest
times hope is the light that lists us
out of darkness darkness let's go save
the universe
keep riding the lightning everyone has a
corpse clay the multiverse needs you
[Music]
welcome back everyone its charlie we
have a whole bunch of new footage to
break down Wonderwoman 1984 trailer and
crisis on Infinite Earths final trailer
they're billing it as the final crisis
trailer but obviously Final Crisis is a
very different big comic book event than
crisis on Infinite Earths if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos and we'll do a DC
merch giveaway all you have to do to
enter that is just be a subscriber and
leave your favorite moment from the
trailers on the video I got to say a
Wonder Woman lassoing lightning bolts is
probably the craziest action scene that
I think I've ever seen in a DC movie
crazier in terms of concept like the
idea that you could lasso a lightning
bolt and say like Superman fighting
doomsday and carrying him into orbit
will break everything down we'll start
with a Wonder Woman footage obviously
and then I'll talk about the crisis on
Infinite Earths footage because episode
1 of crisis on Infinite Earths
will be Sunday night so I will be doing
Easter Egg videos for each of those
episodes we start with footage of Wonder
Woman looking out over a foreign city a
lot of the movie takes place in
Washington DC but this doesn't look like
Washington DC Chris Pine Steve Trevor
voice-over saying the world needs you
obviously in most of the footage in this
trailer or the teaser for the trailer
Steve Trevor is standing right next to
her wearing that weird Members Only
jacket remember the full title of the
movie is Wonder Woman 1984 because the
movie takes place in 1984 so everything
has gone full-blown 80's the reason why
patty Jenkins said that she wanted to do
the movie during that time period is
because it was maximum America
everything was heightened to the maximum
extreme it was the height of the Cold
War the height of 80's excess the height
of everyone's egos obviously that plays
into a little of what the villain
Maxwell Lord is doing like she says
greatness is not what it seems she's
probably talking to Maxwell Lord during
that voiceover then there's the scene of
Wonder Woman protecting Steve Trevor
from what seems like White House
security guards it just seems like she's
in the White House during this scene
maybe they're being mind-controlled by
Maxwell Lord or he does something to
make them think that Wonder Woman is
after the president otherwise why would
they be shooting at Wonder Woman because
it's 1984 the president at this time
would be Ronald Reagan there's this cool
extended scene of her using her lasso in
a much more elaborate takedown scene
than we saw them tried during the first
Wonder Woman movie or Batman V Superman
like any of the other movies that Wonder
Woman has appeared in you could just see
that they've evolved the level of her
action scenes as they've slowly figured
out what they can do with her on a
technical level like how do you make
Galasso seem cool in action scenes
there's a really cool slow-mo shot of
her using her gauntlets to disarm the
gun deflect the bullets into something
else
they also used this slow mode to
cleverly show you the minor changes that
they made to her costume see how much
deeper the colors are and how much more
she just pops on screen when she's
wearing it against the background this
is a really quick comparison of the
color grading from each of the different
movies that she's been in it's the same
costume they just made minor toons and
edits to it in the way that they color
correct each of the films this just
seems like some local disaster near the
Capitol building in Washington DC Wonder
Woman and Steve Trevor approaching in
her civilian ATS clothes this outfit you
probably recognize is also meant to be
almost identical to Lynda Carter's
outfit from the 70s Wonder Woman series
there are a lot of rumors about Lynda
Carter having a cameo in this movie
because she didn't appear during the
first Wonder Woman movie why would you
not have a Lynda Carter cameo in a
Wonder Woman movie also rumors about her
appearing during crisis on Infinite
Earths but I don't know if they were
able to land her for that they said that
they were still trying to do it a while
ago
Wonder Woman has that voice over saying
nothing good comes from lies that's
probably her speaking to Maxwell Lord he
is supposed to be the main villain of
the movie played by Pedro Pascal who is
also the mandalorian so if you're really
digging the Mandalorian there is a whole
lot of Pedro Pascal going around right
now
she says greatness is not what you think
while they show Maxwell Lord inside some
sort of mechanical device that maybe
amplifies his telepathic powers very
quantum leap looking which is also an
80s series but the tiles on the outside
also kind of remind me of cerebro from
the x-men franchise it's not clear who
this dude is firing the giant gun but
it's him probably just trying to take
down Wonder Woman and then obviously the
crazy action scene of her actually
trying to lasso lightning bolts in the
atmosphere to fly through the sky it's
not clear why she's up so high in the
atmosphere maybe she jumps out of a
plane or something like that but this is
just a crazy idea remember she is a
full-blown demigod the half daughter of
Zeus so she can channel lightning at
least a little bit the same way that
Zeus does the full trailer will drop
tomorrow of
course I will do an Easter Egg video for
that so that'll probably be my first
video that I post tomorrow but getting
into crisis on Infinite Earths footage
the voice-over at the beginning is Kevin
Conroy is Batman saying there was no
hope for this world so he does sound
like he comes from an alternate earth
but because Batwoman recognizes him
instantly as Bruce Wayne and he
recognizes her it also sounds like
they're applying a version of earth-1
Batman is also Kevin Conroy as Batman
they'll clear a lot of that up after
crisis speaking of big crossovers they
did talk about Green Lantern being ready
to go by the end of next year as well as
a Booster Gold series and the star girl
series they dropped a teaser for that
but that's more of a high-school series
that's gonna air on the CW so that's not
really relevant to what's going on
during crisis the other really big thing
that people are talking about in this
trailer is the death of Superman scene
that they have here with Tyler hoechlin
Superman's seemingly dead in a scene
that's ripped right off of the comic
book page the big difference here is
that if you read the text on the news
release here the little banner it says
that Lex Luthor appeared out of nowhere
killed Superman then vanished without a
trace so they're talking about Jon
Cryer's version of Lex Luthor obviously
doomsday does not figure into this it
doesn't sound like they're using him
during crisis on Infinite Earths or
anything like that the whole idea is
that there's a version of Lex Luthor
working with the monitor so it's not
clear if it's that version of Lex Luthor
or if it's going to be some other
alternate earth version because Tyler
hoechlin is all over the crisis trailer
it would be kind of weird to be
straight-up dies in the middle of it
because we know that he's going to get a
solo series on the CW next year there
will be a Superman TV show starring his
version of Superman so either they're
gonna pull some big reverse and save him
or this just happens to be an alternate
earth version because it's crisis on
Infinite Earths as in many many
different versions of Superman out there
more of Bury recruiting black lightning
that doesn't happen till the third
episode they kind of cut up this a whole
bunch because there's three different
episodes there's one Sunday night
there's one Monday night one Tuesday
night and then they go on break and they
come back for two more episodes in
January they're really laying it on
thick with everybody crying in this I
mean if if you've ever seen any of these
big crossovers then you know that the
mains from most of these TV shows not
including arrow press F in the chat will
be coming back
or crisis there's still a couple people
out there that have never read crisis on
Infinite Earths
or encountered pictures of what happened
during crisis even if you haven't read
it you probably seen people talk about
what happens during crisis probably the
other biggest new surprise from this
trailer is Wil Wheaton himself carrying
that sign prepared to meet they do the
end of the world is nigh the reason why
he's starring in this is because he
played some Justice League characters in
the early 2000s and some of the animated
series so he has been part of the DC
Universe before they show you Jonah Hex
if it wasn't clear Jonah Hex is going to
be part of this crossover I don't know
how much he's going to be a part of it
you get a whole bunch more of those
shadow demons that are minions of the
anti-monitor coming to fight them on
earth 38 this might be in the first
couple of episodes because the last
trailer makes it seem like they
completely wipe earth 38 at the end of
whatever the first half of this
crossover is there might be a couple
other clips but what'll happen is is
there's so much stuff happening in the
next couple of days we have the last
couple of episodes of watchmen dr.
Manhattan is finally showing up on that
show so I might wind up having to skip
my Watchmen video because we have the
Wonder Woman trailer that's happening
tomorrow afternoon
then we have the first episode of crisis
which will be Sunday night but if you
have any big questions that you want me
to address in my videos tomorrow just
let me know in the comments for a stark
contrast click here to watch the
brand-new trailer for the boys season 2
definitely the antidote to regular
superhero action and click here for the
brand-new Mandalorian episode 5 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]